back here on the Rich Eisen show will be
on fantasy zone on DirecTV channel seven
oh four this weekend once again Michael
what do I do with a hater in the mix
what should I do here just what you did
shame him and drag him you know he
should embrace the fact that the Red Sox
are irrelevant they're gonna continue to
be irrelevant Yankees are the other dogs
yep we're we're America's Sweetheart now
we're gonna dismantle the Astros just
like we dismantled the Indians and we're
gonna be playing in a good old effect
good old-fashioned resurgent World
Series just like the good old days with
Tommy Lasorda Billy Moore and Reggie
Jackson in the fellas that's what the
people want to see people don't want to
see the Boston Red Sox nobody cares okay
take your fishing rod get your mountain
boots go fishing go hiking brockman it's
over okay it's party's over
mm-hmm Division back-to-back ears plus
one plus one cares okay it don't mean a
thing if you ain't got a ring okay so we
got a division banner in there you're
gonna wear a ring this year we're gonna
beat the Dodgers okay Fenway Park is
still a dump and I didn't come here to
argue with you about baseball you know
and you know what you know what rich you
know what's interesting
I am literally you might hear a little
background noise yeah I am literally on
57th and seventh a diamond yeah basking
in the Sun literally I'm gonna send a
picture afterwards literally basking in
the Sun and the victory of me
dismantling you how dare you try to
divert the attention from me beating
your team last week and try to have me
attack Brocklin shame on you my friend
you acknowledge that I beat you yet no
Michael I'm still too busy distracting
you let's talk about Lavar ball what
about this guy and his father and all
this stuff
first of all all the talk all the
heights all the big baller bull crap
always some early looking
looks like the MVP look how gradient
first of all I said it when I was when I
was on this show during the summertime I
said the big three game that I was I was
a sideline reporter we're more
competitive than the NBA Summer League
and people were laughing at me now can
we all acknowledge that the summer
league at the NBA is it joke it means
absolutely nothing listen I don't I
think Lanza Bolt may or may not there's
no guarantees he may or may not be a
good player in the NBA blame his father
he's got an X on his back what a welcome
to the NBA that Patrick Beverley gave
him last night
this ain't Chino Hills this ain't AAU he
took his heart literally took his heart
in the first two minutes of the game and
he was dazed and confused and his father
is still going on still talking still
adding fuel to the fire and it's gonna
be like this all season long there's no
guarantees for Alonzo ball that he's
going to you know continue to you know
thrive in the NBA greater players more
accomplished players couldn't make it in
the NBA you know Adam Morrison was the
player of the year in college Doug
McDermott proved last night that you
could be the Player of the Year and then
still be Doug McDermott on the New York
Knicks um the fact that ESPN puts Lavar
ball on the show this is a former the
former world wide leader and leader in
sports and then after of the after the
game they have this circus act on
they're talking him to an shenanigans
the whole thing is a joke and you know
he got what he got what you know you
know what's coming to him in terms of
people no one would have known would
have cared about Lanza ball you would
have been a good player and he could
develop now he's going to be exploited
and looked at every single night and if
I was guarding him right off the top I
would be like I got this guy this is my
son I'm gonna own him and I'm gonna own
him all night I would say it right to
his face as soon as we came out for the
jump ball like he got his heart taking
lesson and the fact that his father and
you know his father had a reputation for
heckling kids when they were just kids
in these AAU games and the fact that
he's heckling and talking crap to
Patrick Beverley in the NBA that they're
bringing this circus show to the NBA it
really
it really is it's it's a shame and and
you know the NBA needs to be careful
because this is pro sport this is an
aside act this isn't you know wrestling
it's the NBA I think it's going to be an
interesting year you know I think it's
gonna be a really fun year did you do
the game last night with the the Chiefs
in the Raider no no no my next game that
I'm doing for the NFL Network is right
there in New York City between the Jets
and the bills to kick-off week nine and
then that that's the next one um that
I'm doing for the NFL Network that was
incredible last night man and I did I
did not have the gumption to play Amari
Cooper last night I just thought he was
gonna have another one of those weeks
and um I'm one of that type of people
this morning in the few minutes I have
with you left here Michael give me your
usual give me somebody that that that's
gonna have a good week seven and then
some money we should avoid unlike my
play that I made with Amari Cooper last
night well I'm with you on that because
in my other league unfortunately I sat
him and you know what I've always said
that I love a Maury and hopefully so you
know research him and get him focused
and get his confidence back
I had 49 points in the league that I
have them I had 49 Amari Cooper points
on the bench and that's why this is
fantasy football at the end of the day
is it's just so much fun because you
truly never know and and if you if you
started them great if you didn't start
them you know you feel the pain but to
me that is the beauty and the essence of
what's so much fun about fantasy
football and how it really does
translate to regular football so I'm
glad for Amari Cooper I'm mad for my own
team I feel no sympathy that you didn't
start them um but this is what we got
this week okay first of all don't
believe the hype ever never ever ever
when Phillip Rivers is playing Denver I
don't care if he's playing in Denver I
don't care if he's playing in San Diego
I care if he's playing in LA or Lund a
the London don't do it okay so if
anybody has Phillip Rivers don't start
him because he might he might under
exceed even your lowest expectations
believe the hype the only thing that the
San Francisco 49ers have this week
Kittel Kittles start him he's going to
do his thing I think my man fournette is
out
Chris Ivory is due for one of his weird
big games he's a guy you could believe
the highways and believe the hype
believe it or not Brett Hundley is going
to have a very good weekend oh yeah good
good receivers he's athletic he's
confident he's got a chip on his
shoulder and he's got something to prove
I think he's been groomed I think he's
been waiting and I think he's going to
have a very good weekend Ingram and
those guys in New Orleans this is it you
can't do it this weekend I'm jumping off
the ship okay Michael Thomas I'm jumping
off the ship if they can't do it but
Brett Hundley is to me he's gonna be the
guy who's gonna have the biggest weekend
it was gonna surprise I'm not gonna say
he's going to be you know Aaron Rodgers
or Tom Brady because Tom Brady and all
the de New England Patriots absolutely
truly believe the hype on what they're
going to do but I think Brett Huntley is
gonna have a good week a good first
biggest prize that I feel like you've
got a nice confidence about well I mean
that that's a I mean everybody's always
looking for a quarterback maybe to pick
up where if yours is on a bye week or
something like that
certainly all those that got him a
deshaun Watson train that might need
somebody that's uh that's a that's a
nice interesting although potentially
risky play but Mark Ingram at a pretty
good week last week with Adrian Peterson
in Arizona you know but you're right
Michael Thomas it's it's time for him to
step up in a way that I think fantasy
owners have been waiting you think Julio
Jones goes off against the Patriots
Michael what do you think I think
normally Julio Jones would go off
against the Patriots I don't think he's
healthy I mean I would love to see him
go off you know I get nothing but joy
Rahman even though I have a lot of
Patriots on my on my team I'd rather my
fantasy football team loses and you know
I care about my fantasy football team
Iran I rather they lose and and Atlanta
Falcons destroy them but I just feel
like Julio is not Julio and I think that
uh unfortunately I think the Patriots
are going to put the magic sauce on on
everybody this weekend and that's going
to be a fun game and you know and you
know these these critics you know these
political critics that have been saying
the ratings are down for a lot of the
layman regular Joe fans not the crazy
lunatics like us Sunday night is when
the ratings start boosting and as did
the average Joe fan get back into
football
so I'm wagging my tongue here on 7th
Avenue about that yes about to say that
we come full circle started with the
Boston hate ends with the Boston aid and
in the middle the first ever
Lavar ball takedown and fantasy football
update on the corner outside of Carnegie
Hall maybe in the history of that
esteemed building in New York City well
done Michael
absolutely absolutely ready time I'm
telling you I'm gonna send you a picture
you post I literally have suntan lotion
it's a beautiful fall day okay I look
fantastic
I'm tanning just a little bit you know I
have like a 55 on I usually sleep with
some blocker but it's so beautiful and
the fact that you didn't acknowledge my
win and I had to do it just goes to show
where your head's at these days know
what is it no it's okay Michael it's
just listen we don't in in the media pay
attention to one win teams it's just
that simple notice we didn't talk about
the Giants in this conversation just
here's what you need to do take the
picture of you in front of either
Carnegie Hall or the Russian Tea Room
okay okay and then and then and then tag
us and we'll tweet it out yeah okay you
take care of mine not a problem
you gotta you're the man take care
that's Michael Rapaport for more Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen
show app